[Music]
so guys if you had to stay at an airbnb
what's the what's the most terrifying
thing that could possibly happen
camera's in it and then somebody breaks
in tries to kill us not bad if someone's
been in the closet and they wait till
the last minute for us to sleep so they
can [ __ ] stick their dicks in our
mouths oh my wow god but that might be
nice the rate's really good they bait
you in and then like the cleaning fee is
like 2x the rate and most people sleep
with their mouth open they're like ah
didn't
jam a [ __ ] into it
there you go uh maybe having an airbnb
in a very remote place
that's kind of scary too because why i
don't know it's just an implication hold
you hostage ransom because nobody knows
where the [ __ ] you're at
i think
so a woman in florida
she went to stay at an airbnb in tulum
mexico oh i liked her
hoping to have a fun vacation
instead
once they got there the main guest and
her friends believed they were about to
become sex trafficking victims oh my god
like it was it was the way the setup was
so there was mysterious uh splatters of
paint on the door which she thought
looked like blood but she's like maybe
i'm being [ __ ] dramatic and [ __ ]
right so she contacts the concierge and
she is told there's no cause for alarm
it's paint and then you know but that
was her first warning sign she's like
okay maybe i'm being [ __ ] crazy but
whatever i'm in a different place i'm
staying in airbnb so i just want to be
careful yeah and you're looking forward
to a good time you don't want to have a
reason to go back home you're getting
ready to take good instagram pictures
and stuff you're there to take the
graham photos let's be real we all know
what to loom's for yeah seaweed yeah
mostly seaweed in the summer you're not
swimming in those beaches uh because you
like how the water is no you're swimming
in there
hey there it is
um so then all of a sudden you know they
realized there's no way to lock the
bedroom that's alarming like um so
there's keypads right and they weren't
set for the rooms it would essentially
give everyone access to the rooms at any
time so you couldn't lock it because
they're all that keypad but you can't
lock it
also even like the front door
is it a scene it's like a home but then
there's no bedroom so you could lock the
front door right but you couldn't lock
the bedrooms inside of the domicile okay
that's not i'm not i'm not triggered yet
yeah there's a lot of homes like that
but they thought that was weird okay
okay that was weird
um the third problem happened three days
into the stay when an unknown man
claiming to be a security guard
started standing in front of the house
and just waiting that's weird did he
have a security sign on his t-shirt but
that's easy he's getting it on the back
of his teeth oh the back okay okay all
right yeah and then he had he had that
uh fbi shirt in the front okay
your favorite body inspector yeah yeah
okay
little sus little little sauce but it
checked out they actually looked them up
he was with the female body inspectors
so it was totally fine on the up and up
so then um she reaches out again she's
like yo what's with the security guard
so she reaches out and um to the airbnb
like messaging yeah to the concierge and
the owner
no response oh spooky so she and her
friends
maybe a little dramatically go to bed
with knives next to their
um pillows okay what if they stab
themselves because they roll over and
they [ __ ] go like this on the pillow
huge cause of normal deaths yeah happens
all the time so three of them died that
way
and that's the end of the article that's
the article that's what happens it's
crazy um these pieces were dramatic
um no so so then they checked out the
very next day
and it wasn't until they contacted
airbnb directly and said the concierge
instead of talking to the host right
she heard back from the homeowner who
only offered her a 67 refund when the
total
um was
six hundred seventy one dollars
man i could have got her a huge hookup
dude
she she's stupid escapes um she then uh
leaves a bad review right
and noticed that her review got deleted
how
right
uh they don't know they're trying to
find out so how the [ __ ] is airbnb
cleaning this up well when they when she
shared the experience online with others
other women came out with similar
accusations against the same exact owner
and property
and after receiving a string of bad
reviews
the owner changed their name and profile
picture on it and then they just created
another one with the same [ __ ] house
uh probably but but they yeah they like
they said they changed their name and
profile picture so they're still on
there how did they almost get sex
traffic though well they don't know
because they just thought they thought
it was a weird house
as [ __ ] it's getting closer and closer
but there's not that one defining oh
there's a dude standing outside it's
like almost security for the house and
then nobody can confirm that like why
would you have that and also fellow
women specifically having other
complaints or reviews that were deleted
or something but you know what the weird
part is right they all got away yeah no
they got only the ones that left reviews
yeah yeah but the thing is like there's
no there's no successful attempt but you
wouldn't know that's that's because no
no no no here here's the thing right
they should they suck at being abductors
all these people are not aggressive they
don't pull the trigger fair fair they're
too nervous to pull their pussyfoot yeah
yeah why why
all these people got away they're
writing all these reviews they're
tattling on them yeah you're gonna tell
them you might as well have you as my
sex driver geek victim
maybe just keep your friends close but
keep your enemies close oh that's
interesting but they're strangers how
they enemies
now they are because they listen to
better
oh okay okay okay or maybe they're like
they're watching through cameras and
they're like [ __ ] these [ __ ] are
sleeping with knives oh
yeah yeah yeah
why do we keep why do we keep leaving
knives in the house and like they're
just like what if they roll over and
kill themselves
three of them died that way
i would be asleep i'll be afraid to
sleep with a knife or something i would
too bro i want to under the pillow
i move around way too much when i sleep
i pull my trigger fingers way too much
do all kinds of weird [ __ ] with my hands
at night because my hands are falling
asleep [ __ ] wake up with my knives
all like all over my arms and [ __ ] all
bleeding issues i remember going to
sleep with markers as a kid i woke up
[ __ ] color in the whole [ __ ] bed
i remember i forgot what happened by
slipping markers and the caps fell off
and then [ __ ] there's [ __ ] marker
marks on my pillowcase my neck all over
the
place
i like how bart passed out dead asleep
is the same as bart completely awake
with legos
[Laughter]
he's like i'm getting carried away over
what's going on
i burned the house down and he's like
well i was playing with legos one thing
led to another and then oopsie poopsie
it's all on fire you know when you just
get into a flow yep you're playing with
legos
the way that he tried to relate to us
yesterday with that and we're all like
what are you [ __ ] talking about when
you go deep in legos and you ruin
everything one thing leads to another
you know you know that phrase you're
doing coke everywhere dude [ __ ] up his
rc car
so good [ __ ] you guys your video earlier
video reference hopefully this is an
order it never is it's fine whatever
we'll deal with it later i never blamed
him i deserved it so the reason why
honorable friends the reason why maybe
these women were a little on edge right
is because
in 2018
uh there was a reported incident that
police in toronto
stated that they noticed a growing trend
of airbnb rentals being used for human
trafficking so this is kind of out there
like following two recent arrests in the
greater toronto area and that's just
toronto right in 2020 airbnb ramped up
their efforts to combat this by joining
forces with a service called polaris
which is a trafficking non-profit also
the owner of slingshot oh really the
three-wheeled car polaris though i think
it is i think it's dope thermoses dope
[ __ ] um sport thermoses for your
water yes very good it's a conglomerate
it's nice oh it's the same polaris that
did the cars no it's i don't know
this is why you could trick a dancer do
whatever you want
that's why zoolander had that bit about
you could assassinate the [ __ ] prime
minister of micronesia yeah with the
[ __ ] dancer because the do whatever
the [ __ ] you absolutely want we're the
[ __ ] best assassins yeah because you
don't even know what's going on
you passed a lie detector test having
been a murderer and they're like he
doesn't even know what's going on can
you get back to the the girls in the
knives that killed themselves
no i think we're gonna stay on this one
right uh yeah so so uh listen you're not
even reading half the article dude
i'm making it up it's a blank sheet of
paper
i made this all up wholesale not paper
[Laughter]
can you hurry up so
the rental company faced criticism
because it wasn't doing enough to combat
the problem of sex trafficking in
response airbnb rolled out this
aggressive plan
combined with polaris
and that this included in-person host
training according to usa today this
would help the
host community identify signals or
triggers and the nature and style of the
reservation like little hints that maybe
you could notice when you're trying to
book it yeah it's crazy how prevalent
this is because when we did our writer's
retreat remember i think it was like
manhattan beach or some [ __ ] they had a
play card yeah it was a regular hotel
like marriott or whatever and then it's
there's like signs like if you see signs
of sex trafficking that's a little
different that's a little different
though because it's like a hotel so it's
like hotels and airports too but that's
what seemed like a pretty good area it
was just like a regular area would bring
him through though it wasn't even next
to an airport either it was like the
most randomest hotel yeah it wasn't like
in tulum or mexico or anything like that
what are those happenings
i mean really yeah there's gonna be
grounds for like a class action lawsuit
against airbnb or some [ __ ] though well
there's no real damages i mean nothing
really happened
so so they're not even suing or anything
they're just trying to let people know
and be aware in fact that's actually why
i brought this article up just because
this is kind of [ __ ] we always think
about the cameras and stuff like that
airbnb but like think about [ __ ] like
this is like a whole nother level yeah
well so canada reports two incidents or
or uh arrests people there's obviously
uh some other like forum or
conversational discussion thread that's
talking about other women that have had
problems the same blah blah
so what about like stats or reports on
uh
missing people or things that were where
there was quote unquote successful human
trafficking
yeah
yeah it obviously wasn't this one
because they're very unsex
unsuccessful
they're not good at getting girls there
they're probably a startup that they're
just practicing i feel like they're like
those robbers and all right this one i'm
gonna rob this house they're like no no
that's too it's too nice okay are we
gonna rob it this time are they like
they're like 90s robbers like 90s surfer
robbers really whoa dude
we're gonna have to rob these guys huh
bro
okay yeah but i'm kind of hungry dawg
okay dude we'll let's eat and then we'll
rob the house dude
and they keep failing you know
[Music]
you